[Musique]
parlons d'europe
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de parlons d'europe sur radio
sensations et en partenariat avec tv 78
et de l'homme la maison de l'europe des
yvelines à numéro spécial alors que se
déroule en ce moment là qu potvin
conférence des nations unies sur le
climat à glascow en écosse
c'est l'occasion pour nous de vous
parler du projet et domaine vers l'huile
d'alcan de jumelage et de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines mais d'abord la
crise sanitaire at elle changé votre
vision de l'avenir c'est la question que
nous sommes allés vous posez la crise
sanitaire at elle changé votre vision de
l'avenir
voilà c'est comme question basse cette
crise a rendu les choses un peu plus
précaire au niveau de l'emploi quant à
moi je recherche d'emploi et si à cause
si directement à cause de la crise et on
essaye de faire la part mais c'est pas
toujours facile
et ça nous a montré que nous et que la
mondialisation n'est pas la panacée
l'avenir inquiète je suis très inquiète
pour l'avenir et que nous sommes pas
préparés à des épreuves comme ça au
niveau sanitaire on n'a pas voulu pas au
niveau très bien on va continuer on va
se pencher sur l'engagement des jeunes
en faveur de l'environnement avec cette
chronique de mathieu écouter les jeunes
générations sont en première ligne face
aux dérèglements climatiques pour
préserver leur avenir imaginaire mon
meilleur pour demain la jeunesse
s'engage d'après laden les problèmes
environnementaux sont ceux qui
inquiètent le plus les jeunes en 2001 12
% des 18-24 ans serait engagée dans
cette cause contre 6 en 2016 c'est le
double cependant les jeunes sont encore
peu impliqué lorsqu'il s'agit de passer
à l'action par manque de sensibilisation
de motivation et peut-être même de
soutien alors si on te disait que c'est
une manière d'affirmer qu'il ya de
l'évolution que les entreprises s'y
mettent et surtout tu n'es pas le seul à
préoccuper de ce sujet peut-être que tu
aurais envie de s'engager avec nous
tiens pour motiver sache que la dernière
marche pro climat a réuni près de 50000
personnes à paris dont 110 milles dans
tout france que la dernière pétition la
sphère du siècle a réuni près de 2
millions de signatures
avec l'initiative on est prêt les
influenceurs se sont même engagés à nos
côtés la jeunesse s'engage pour son
futur alors n'ai pas peur de passer à
l'action toi aussi la jeunesse s'engage
pour son futur n'ai pas peur de passer à
l'action toi aussi c'est un bel appel
que nous nous lance un mathieu regin a
lecointe bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoints vous êtes la sécrétaire général
de la maison de l'europe des yvelines et
la présidente de l'association des amis
du jumelage saint germain en laye et
aschaffenburg csssae bonjour
qu'est ce qui vous a séduit dans l'appel
à projets de l'ofa jo fils franco
allemande pour la jeunesse qui a fait
vous avez voulu participer à jeunes et
pleins d'europe c'est ce qui m'a séduit
c'est surtout mon côté présidente
jumelage parce que nous on essaye
d'engager quand même le dialogue
franco-allemand avec les jeunes et bons
à thématique ça concerne surtout les
jeunes parce que c'est leur avenir etc
nous on essaie leur dire engagez vous
réagissez parce que
vos parents votre environnement n'est
peut-être pas aussi rapides ne voient
pas le danger comme vous vous le voyez
pas ce que vous allez le vivre nous on
sera plus là mais c'est tout de suite
qu'il faut réagir et pas attendre vingt
voire trente ans
on a demandé tout à l'heure aux gens si
la crise sanitaire avait changé leur
vision de l'avenir et vous l'at elle
changé si oui c'était con oui ça
certainement à accélérer mais on a déjà
ses avantages de l'âge ça fait déjà 30
ans plus de trente ans qu'on est un peu
dans cette vision il faut changer
quelque chose pour suivre tous parce que
on est de plus en plus nombreux sur
terre
de faire quelque chose pour ne pas
ruiner notre terre notre vie et il faut
faire quelque chose
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on veut tous
ce que vous pouvez expliquer un petit
peu si on veut tout se sait quoi
l'impact l'influent sur l'environnement
la façon dont on vit la façon dont
travaille l'industrie qui peut être pré
pull polluantes mais aussi nous avec nos
petits gestes on peut être très polluant
je reviens de berlin quand on est allé à
berlin il y avait trois rangs de gros
camions sur la route de paris jusqu'à
berlin ça pour moi ce sont des grands
pools heures il faudrait sortir tout ça
de l'autoroute et mettre sur les rails
par exemple des
bons l'allemagne
qui se dit très écologique mais le
charbon et qu'elle traite toujours là
vraiment du mal à 100
par tia et chassant son décès c'est
vraiment des grands questions
environnementales il faut les attaquer
et très rapidement et justement original
contre vous êtes d'origine allemande
vouvet en france quelles sont les
différences de perception de
l'environnement est-ce qu'en allemagne
on est plus verte aux océans france vous
pouvez faire la différence aux
bisons que dans les petites choses dans
les gestes du quotidien les anneaux ont
certainement de la vence sur sur les
français ça a commencé avec les three
des des poubelles là ça n'existait pas
encore en france où on faisait ça déjà
depuis longtemps et d'autre les
mouvements vers c'était plutôt que
en france par contre on est des très
grands rouleurs comme je disais sur le
charbon
donc les allemands de temps en temps il
faudra quand même être un peu plus
modeste sur
il n'est pas dire on est premier de la
classe c'est pas vrai parce que les
grands pollueurs aussi niveau là c'est
les allemands mais j'ai aussi côté
français l'énergie atomique
pour moi c'est pas vraiment écologique
parce que il faut refroidir
les grands et ça ça veut dire chauffer
l'eau
utilisée l'eau
monter la température dans les rivières
tuer les poissons donc tout il ya des
choses à repenser on a vraiment besoin
et très rapidement de trouver des
solutions vraiment
durable tous vos explications nous
conduit vers la mode d'industrie le
monde d'industrie à quel point il faut
changer les quotidiennes à quel point il
faut changer est évidemment au niveau de
l'industrie
vous aviez parlé tout à l'heure de
l'énergie atomique vous avez parlé de
l'énergie charbon etc il faut trouver
des moyens pour produire l'énergie
différemment on a des airs lien ça aussi
c'est quand même disputé pas tout le
monde aime on à l'énergie solaire après
il faut savoir parce que si par exemple
on veut avoir des voitures que
électrique bah ma foi et ça veut dire il
faut au moins doubler
l'électricité pour avoir pour les
quotidiens et pour l'usagé des voitures
et quand il ya des grands froids comment
on fait
comment gère donc tout ça on a des idées
mais après il faut savoir comment ça
s'applique quels sont les atouts quels
sont les dangers
etc on revient sur le projet regina
lecointe qu'elle quels seront les temps
forts fort du projet et domaine 20
villes d'art quand
c'est surtout de faire réfléchir
les jeunes parce que la pandémie sa
frappe et beaucoup de monde et ça
surtout frappé les jeunes qui se sont
retrouvés des cours ils avaient tous les
libertés liberté que nous à nos âges on
n'avait même pas mais des coups ils se
sont fait renfermé dans l'eure dans leur
maison pouvait plus parler que
et donc les réflexions devenez
différents et
la grande question était comment on va
continuer après cette pandémie ça peut
pas on ne peut pas recommencer comme
avant il faut que les choses changent et
c'est ça nous c'était surtout l'idée de
dire on va réfléchir ensemble on va vous
en citer non seulement à réfléchir et à
avoir des idées de discuter avec des
élus et aussi avec vous
vos camarades à voir il existe
maintenant des éco délégués dans
les lycées donc vous faites un peu d
effet boule de neige on a participé à ce
projet donc maintenant on va vous en
forme et on va réfléchir ensemble et il
faut que
qu'ils soient et des multiplicateurs de
ce message il faut qu'on bouge
maintenant est comment en bouche qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour que ça soit
vraiment bien et durable c'est ça
surtout
merci régulière d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup mieux l'orgueil et
mathieu à votre échelle et vous avec vos
moyenne à travers ce projet on va voir
que vous avez aussi un rôle de lanceur
d'alert vous êtes là aussi pour nous
sensibiliser aux quotidiennes on va
ainsi s'intéresser à notre consommation
de viande en 2017 ce sont 3 123 millions
de tonnes de viande qui ont été
produites dans le monde une production
massive excessif qui n'est pas sans
conséquence sur notre environnement quel
est donc l'impact environnemental de la
production et consommation de viande
d'abord cette activité qui englobe la
production la transformation des
aliments pour les bêtes le stockage et
le traitement des chimie ainsi que le
transport et met environ 7 milliards de
tonnes de co2 par an soit plus que les
etats-unis et la france réunies
d'autre part cette production notamment
concernant le porc et le poulet pose de
gros problèmes environnementaux en
termes de pollution des eaux en effet le
régime très riche en nutriments des
animaux entraîne un taux d'azoté
supérieur à la normale dans les eaux
rejetées et peut même provoquer des
problèmes de santé publique il est
intéressant de noter que c'est la
production de viande combinée à celle
des produits laitiers et mais la moitié
des gaz à effet de serre liées à
l'alimentation elles ne représentent
pourtant que 20 % des calories ingérées
au niveau mondial en termes de
ressources due aux élevages intensifs
la production de viande est très friande
en eau et en céréales ce qui pose des
problèmes en matière de gestion et de
durabilité des ressources
concernant les céréales la part produite
est révolté qui sert uniquement à
nourrir le bétail représente 800
millions de tonnes soit assez pour
nourrir 3 milliards et 2000 d'êtres
humains enfin l'élevage grignotent aussi
la forêt amazonienne dans la mesure où
le manque de terres agricoles pousse à
la déforestation toutes les terres
prétendument récupérer certains alors au
pâturage ou à la production de sora au
de soja pour nord pour nourrir par la
suite le bétail et le problème c'est que
moins de forêts il n'y a moins
d'émissions de dioxyde de carbone sont
absorbés face à une production mondiale
qui ne cesse d'augmenter il est
essentiel de se demander quelle solution
nous pouvons apporter tout d'abord une
étude parue en 2013 montre que
l'empreinte eau des européens liés à
l'alimentation pourrait baisser du tiers
en diminuant la part de viande dans les
repas en ce sens nous pouvons essayer de
trouver des substituts de protéines
comme les légumineuses tels que les
lentilles par exemple c'est à dire
devenir flexitariens en deux mots
continuer à manger de la viande tout en
réduisant notre impact
nous pouvons également essayé de
consommer plus responsable par exemple
en achetant de la viande élevée en plein
air et locales pour réduire de fait les
gaz à effet de serre dues au transport
devient enfin il pourrait être
intéressant de favoriser les repas
végétariens et végétaliens dans les
administrations par exemple ou dans les
écoles on pourrait mettre en place de
repas végétarien par semaine tant de
solutions sont envisageables il n'ya
plus qu'à passer à l'action en bref
plutôt qu'un steak nous croyons que les
personnes préfèrent hérité d'une planète
habitable tout autre chose à présent la
mode et l'impact sur l'environnement
comme vous nous expliquer la nouvelle
mode ont fait que la mode vestimentaire
et la manière de se vêtir conformément
au goût d'une époque avec des codes
qu'elle impose et le goût individuel on
recense diverses types de modes comme la
fast fashion qui est le fait de
fabriquer des vêtements qui s'inspire du
haut de gamme mais vendus moins chers et
peut-être changé renouveler plus
rapidement et la haute couture qui est
le fait de réaliser des vêtements sur
mesure souvent à la main dans des
ateliers d'au moins 20 personnes
donc quel est l'impact environnemental
de la mode et quelles sont les
alternatives
tout d'abord plus de 100 milliards de
vêtements parents sont vendus dans le
monde en effet selon la dr l'impact
environnement de l'industrie de du
textile est tout d'abord liés à l'eau
car ils sont le troisième secteur le
plus consommateur de dos avec 4 %
tiens utilisation d'eau potable et ils
émettent 2% de gaz à effet de serre
de plus un vêtement de mauvaise qualité
va durer environ 35 jours dans le temps
alors qu'un vêtement d'eau de gamme va
être plus durable
ainsi un vêtement de fast fashion au
premier l'adage peut perdre une demi à
une taille
alors qu'un vêtement de haut de gamme
perd quelques centimètres enfin il ya
diverses alternatives à cet impact et
environnemental avec des bagadoù qui
revendent les invendus comme noz tôt
comme annick clos on peut les acheter
d'occasion brocante vite être le bon
coin emmaüs donnés à des associations
fabrique croix rouge on peut les troquer
à h&m contre des bons d'achat ou à give
ou alors faire cours à son imagination
avec avec la customisation couture
broderie donc à toi d'inventer la mode
que font les jeunes pour l'environnement
quelles sont les initiatives prises dans
les établissements scolaires plusieurs
exemples à suivre
je vous amène à poissy stéphanie tiers
je suis proviseur adjointe du lycée le
corbusier de poissy
quels sont les projets
alors depuis trois ans nous avons créé
un comité d éco délégués donc choisi de
proposer aux élèves d'ailleurs du
collège et du lycée donc de 11 ans à 18
ans de réfléchir de se sensibiliser par
le biais de projets aux différentes
dimensions du développement durable et
les projets prennent de plus en plus une
part active dans notre lycée et nous
sommes accompagnés dans cette démarche
par différents acteurs notamment la
région ile de france alors on a des
projets qui ont soit une dimension liée
à la protection de l'environnement la
protection de la biodiversité donc le
premier projet phare qui maintenant est
sa troisième année c'est l'implantation
de ruches dans l'établissement qui ont
permis aux élèves ensuite de créer un
club apiculture encadrés par des
enseignants et des personnels du lycée
ensuite nous avons eu les prairies
mellifères et aujourd'hui dernière étape
de ce projet multi facettes
l'inauguration de notre hôtel à insectes
mais nous avons aussi notre type de
projet qui est plutôt sur la
préservation
de l'énergie et notamment se projette en
lien avec un projet national qui
s'appelle qu baisse et qui vise à mettre
en place des initiatives locales pour
préserver nos ressources énergétiques
économiser l'énergie dont les lycées il
ya parfois des abeilles mais aussi des
moutons comme au lycée sonia-delaunay de
villepreux je m'appelle roar garneau je
suis enseignante de svt mais je suis
aussi des référents développement
durable et on est au lycée sonia
delaunay à vivre dans le 78
des fois c'est tombé jeudi
c'est un établissement en fait qui c'est
qui ça qu'ils s'impliquent en faveur du
développement durable
qui implique l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'établissement que ce soit aussi bien
les élèves que le personnel technique
que l'administration cpe enseignants à
tous les acteurs de l'osce en
établissement fait vont participer et
collaborer dans le but d'obtenir une
démarche
de développement durable
quelle est votre démarche
donc c'est un établissement en démarche
de développement durable ce label en
fait est délivrée par le rectorat il est
valable pendant trois ans il ya trois
niveaux niveau 1 niveau 2 niveau 3
l'objectif pour chaque établissement
c'est d'atteindre le niveau 3 nous nous
sommes labellisés au niveau 2 ce label
en fête permet ensuite de postuler un
autre dispositif qui lui est géré par la
région qui s'appelle le dispositif lycée
éco responsable donc à partir du moment
où on obtient le label
de 3d on a trois ans et chaque année on
peut postuler au niveau des lycées
éco-responsable et ça ça nous permet
d'obtenir des subventions de la part de
la région ile de france c'est ça qui
nous a permis de financer pas mal de nos
projets donc l'idée c'est de présenter
en fait un projet de soumettre un projet
de budget et le projet ensuite la région
décide si elle investit ou pas dans le
projet en fonction de comment on a monté
notre projet
quels sont les projets
alors les projets qu'on a mis en place
sont divers et variés ça fait déjà
plusieurs années qu'on est en démarche
développement durable avec ont fait
partie justement des lycées
éco-responsable donc on a commencé par
mettre en place en fait un petit jardin
écologique en créant des plates formes à
partir de matériaux recyclés
on a créé des carrés potagers
on a également créé une gré knotek c'est
à dire on collectionne en fait des
graines et on permet aux états membres
de l'établissement d'échangés des
graines on a également créé une haie
végétale on a créé des nichoirs à
oiseaux et on a travaillé aussi sur
l'écopâturage on a installé des bêtes
des brebis à partir de l'année dernière
quatre brebis pâture et ça évite de ton
en fait les pelous et on a également
participé à la gestion des déchets en
créant des poubelles donc les éco
délégués ont créé des poubelles des
poubelles qui permet de recycler en fait
le papier qui sont récupérés par les
agents qui re sic ensuite on est au
studio de nouveau lors guy mines et
mathieu parmi tous ces projets tous ces
actions il y en a que vous connaissiez
déjà et il y a il y en a qui vous
intéressent plus particulièrement je
m'adresse alors
alors moi je dis des moutons je pense
connaissez pas trop cette idée mais
l'apiculture
je crois que ça saigne ça signifie faire
bonne idée et voilà après donc elle
sonne c'est une bonne idée super bonne
idée vous pouvez voter largeur un peu le
cette idée pourquoi vous pensez que
c'est une troupe a déjà ses impôts déjà
levé de métro un projet en place quel
que soit le projet c'est une bonne chose
et ça permet aussi de montrer aux élèves
que c'est possible de changer et qu'il
faut pas qu'ils pensent qu'ici point il
faut pas qu'ils disent oui laisse pas
parce qu'on fait ça que ça va changer
quelque chose pas une petit petit petit
action en fait une petite section peut
changer quelque chose et notamment on
peut prendre pour une star du petit
colibri qui est dans la forêt et qui met
de l'eau dans
oui c'est vrai que c'est bien de voir
des moutons au lycée qu'est ce que vous
pensez par rapport à ceux là oui c'est
mignon mais
l'union d'avoir des animaux lycée bon
c'est pas possible dans tous les lycées
ce qu'il y en ait qui n'ont pas de derb
ou très peu et ça coûte très cher et le
fait d'avoir des animaux déjà ça
sensibilise les élèves à cause animale
et aussi pour l'environnement c'est plus
écologique aux moutons broutent la
l'herbe que utiliser la tondeuse à gazon
je reviens vers mature moitié eau on a
bien vu quelques projets par rapport à
l'environnement au sein des lycées
plutôt oui il y avait des moutons il y
avait d autres projets mais plus
particulièrement que vous intéresse au
niveau des projets qu est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter
déjà je trouve que parmi les quatre
projets qu'on vient de voir
à chaque projet on voit déjà les jeunes
qui s'engagent
dans chacun de ces projets donc vaut
déjà bravo à eux d'avoir mis sept îles
en place dans leur lycée
maintenant moi s'il ya un projet que je
retiendrai plus particulièrement sa
serait le jardin numérique du lycée
international parce que on montre et on
cherche une nouvelle façon de cultiver
donc là on avait des prototypes mise en
place par exemple sur cultivées où il ya
eu aussi l'arrosage donc mieux arroser
qu'en vol dans les champs par exemple on
va analyser des litres d'eau alors qu'il
n'a peut-être pas forcément besoin
justement je pense que la technologie
qui est quand même la route dans l'ère
du numérique
et bien si on peut mettre à contribution
toute cette technologie dans la
protection de l'environnement jean
lutherie l'utile à l'agréable
merci merci et matteo pour terminer dès
direction le lycée international de
saint germain en laye qui a travaillé
sur un projet de jardin numérique je
m'appelle le cargo stylo et je suis
professeur de mathématiques au lycée
international de saint germain en laye
quels sont les projets
c'est un projet qui s'appelle étude des
jardins numérique c'est un projet qu'on
l'a initié l'année dernière au lycée
international en septembre et qui avait
comme objectif de faire découvrir la
dynamique de projets aux élèves par le
biais d'un sujet car la fois intéressant
et un qui constitue un enjeu pour le
monde contemporain à savoir les
problèmes liés à l'écologie les élèves
ont conçu
de maquettes il m'a 15 pour créer un
arrosage automatique de plantes afin
d'étudier l'utilisation de l'eau dans un
cadre de potagers et donc en gaspiller
moins et d'autre part ils ont fait une
maquette pour étudier les
caractéristiques biologiques des plantes
et tout particulièrement étudiée là haut
la taille des plantes en fonction du
temps et pouvoir aussi mené des études
scientifiques sur les caractéristiques
de croissance des plantes
nous avons eu un point de départ
extérieur nous avons participé au green
hackaton deux du département de la
région pardon de la région ile de france
qui avait comme thématique qui avait
l'objectif de financer des projets
innovants dans des lycées des collèges
de la région
qui portait sur les thématiques liées à
l'écologie donc à partir de là le champ
était clair et comme je suis en
enseignante de mathématiques on a essayé
de conjuguer un aspect si vous voulez
scientifiques mais aussi technologique
avec de l'informatique un projet plus
lié à la botanique et aux sciences de la
vie et de la terre
les ellipses city sensible du gothique
durable on voit bien que cette
thématique du développement durable
s'installe dans les établissements dans
les classes à plusieurs niveaux
au lycée international nous avons un
club de développement durable qui a
composé de professeurs et élèves qui
travaillent sur les enjeux de cette les
autres problématiques et prépare aussi
la labellisation de l'établissement
comme s'ils suivent il se fait
maintenant dans plusieurs établissements
de notre département on le voit aussi
dans les choix de
de pakour après le bac pour les élèves à
vocation scientifique tout
particulièrement mais pas qu'eux mais
pas que et aussi on l'a vu l'année
dernière dans les choix de questions de
grand oral ce projet a donné l'occasion
aux élèves de se poser des questions en
lien avec les enjeux écologiques mais
avec une application concrète qu'ils ont
pu voir qu'ils ont pu penser et qu'ils
ont pu construire merci encore à nos
invités regin a lecointe de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines et la présidente
de jumelage saint germain en laye et
aschaffenburg leurs limites et mathieu
merci beaucoup à vous trois et vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission au
podcast audio et en vidéo sur notre site
et notre application radio sensations
tivi 78 très bonne soirée et bon week
end
parlons d'europe
[Musique]